hey youtubers is charlie so awesome Star
Wars stuff coming out at d23 this
weekend there's stuff from the force
awakens there's stuff from rogue one the
first spin-off movie and then there's a
whole bunch of stuff about the theme
park so I'm going to start with this
really awesome quote from JJ Abrams
about Gwendoline Christie even though
there wasn't new footage this is one of
my most fun things that I heard about
the movie this weekend so JJ Abrams said
I can only say this about Gwendoline
Christie she's my favorite she killed it
you think well what it's wearing a
costume but it's a lot to wear and to
have a performance when you're wearing
that requires a different kind of skill
set in an additional talent and she's
got it he's talking about Gwendoline
Christie acting with all that gear on
her chrome trooper gear it's an
incredible thing to work with her I'm
glad that a character has been designed
that is as visually stunning as that is
because she deserves it in the fans do
too when I first saw that design my mind
was blown because it looks so undeniable
so you can take a lot of things from
that you know mostly him hyping
Gwendoline Christie a Brienne of Tarth
in space all the new cast looks great
but but of all the villains so far
Gwendoline Christie looks like one of
the best and I mean I mean I'm saying
villain in a very general way we know
she's going to be with the new order
that's what they're calling the Empire
in the new trilogy that doesn't mean
that she's going to be straight up evil
but as far as we know she's playing for
Team dark side when I think of her
character I think of that speech that
Galadriel had during Lord of the Rings
when she was talking to Frodo about you
know when he offered her the ring and
she was like please don't offer that to
me I'd be this beautiful terrible Queen
all would love me in despair as if like
the awesome force radiating from her
chrome trooper gear was going to be
killing you but you couldn't stop loving
her at the same time just one of the
many many things to get hyped about feel
the big villain reveal is Donal
Gleason's character he's kind of playing
the Grand Moff Tarkin of the new film
trilogy like like the military commander
that's in charge the only thing we know
about his name is that it's general Hux
we don't know his full name he's a great
actor so I'm really excited but the
funny thing about it is that he's mostly
known for playing small indie you know
quirky roles so it's really funny to see
him play this towering villain character
so chrome trooper hype aside the next
big reveal or really like the biggest
reveal on my mind is that Finn is
holding a lightsaber in this one sheet
now this isn't going to be the official
poster for the movie this is just a
limited edition that they released
at the convention so only like you know
eight or ten thousand people got this
but it's legit and a lot of people are
actually saying that he's holding Anakin
Skywalker's lightsaber now I don't know
if that's true you can't see the full
health I think the reason people are
saying that it's Anakin's is just
because the color of the blade now if
you remember way way back in the trailer
there is this shot of someone passing a
lightsaber to someone else it looks like
someone's giving it to Leia so I think
the movie is going to invoke a lot of
Skywalker artifacts I don't know if any
of the new characters will be wildung
classic characters lightsabers I think
they just want you to think that in
Wonder speed which JJ Abrams also
clarified a little bit about what's
going on with the names so we know Finn
and we know ray to the big protagonists
along with Oscar Isaacs character
they're kind of like the new han Luke
and Leia you know I'll be it you know
not carbon copies they're kind of
playing with a lot of the conventions of
the classic characters but there's a big
reason why we know Oscar Isaacs full
name but we don't know the full names
are the last names for Finn and Ray JJ
Abrams like just not quite ready to
reveal those yet most people think that
that's because they're related to the
classic characters like there are
children of Skywalker's in this movie
there was another new image here to of
Daisy Ridley's character getting bb-8
from another scavenger it was revealed
that this character's name is Tito and
it's being played by Kieran Shaw he
played an Ewok way way back in episode 6
so it's just another big actor that
they're bringing back in an interesting
way Warwick Davis is also involved with
the production though they haven't
announced to Warwick is playing though
but he was one of the other Ewoks on
episode six there's even like a funny
BTS video that they filmed whenever they
were doing the original trilogy with him
walking around the set in his a walk
gear but as for new footage is probably
going to be october november before we
see another big big trailer JJ Abrams
said it'd be in the fall so I'm
expecting October like late October once
we get within about a month or two of
the film they'll really start rolling
out a bunch of footage I think they
almost posted like half of Avengers age
of Ultron before that movie came out and
like the month preceding moving on to
rogue one so they talked a lot about the
spin-off they released a teaser image
with the main cast the biggest being
Felicity Jones mass mickelson forest
whitaker in alan tudyk from Firefly and
many many other sci-fi things is doing a
motion capture role so his face won't
but his voice will robe one is the story
of the rebels mission to steal the plans
for the original Death Star if you
remember at the beginning of episode 4
Darth Vader's Star Destroyer is chasing
down princess Leia's Carillion Corvette
because he thinks she has the plans so
rogue one takes place before that just
to give you an idea for the vibe of the
movie it feels like it's going to be a
little bit Ocean's eleven little bit
dirty dozen a little bit fast and
furious like a Star Wars fast and
furious movie about them stealing the
plans for the death star from the Empire
so that doesn't get you excited just go
rewatch some of your big favorite heist
movies it's gonna be super high-energy
super awesome heist the only real weird
thing that they said about the spin-off
movies is that instead of calling them
anthology movies they're calling them
star war stories now it seems kind of
weird but you know whatever I mean the
movies will be great that's all I care
about right now rogue one is scheduled
for December 16th of 2016 so you know
about a year after episode 7 the deal is
they want to release a new Star Wars
movie every single year so every two
years we'll get one of the main films
like episode seven eight nine and then
in between those will get the spin-off
movies they did confirmed there is a han
solo movie he would be in his 20s we're
not gonna see like a child han Solo
they're not going to do that prequel
Anakin thing and they're not going to be
doing a lot of Harrison Ford Harrison
Ford might be part of it he might have a
cameo but he's not going to be the star
that film remember as much as they're
invoking the classic cast really like
this new Star Wars franchises Disney is
all about introducing new actors so it's
going to be focusing on all the new
characters the most there was a leaked
image of Luke Skywalker in full Jedi
robes I'm not gonna post it here because
it was definitely a leak and definitely
something that Lucasfilm would get
really pissed about but if you've seen
any of the fan art he looks just like
that it's just his robes were white that
was really the only thing of note the
other big thing is the Star Wars land
like the theme parks that they're
building the one in anaheim in the one
in Orlando they're not breaking ground
on those till 2017 when I say break
ground like literally sticking a shovel
in the ground so the prime not going to
finish them until 2018 so we'll have
already seen episode 8 by the time we
can go visit these places and blow all
our money there they did release a ton
of concept art though and it looks
really awesome I cannot wait to blow all
my money you guys can let me know though
you know what do you think about all
this rogue one episode 7 News what are
you
think about John boyega with the
lightsaber do you think that he's
actually gonna get to wield like one of
the classic characters lightsabers or if
it'll be something new you have to
remember that kylo Ren's character looks
like he built his own lightsaber so it's
not like there are a bunch of lightsaber
just lying around for people to use so I
do like the idea of them passing down
more artifacts like even Luke Skywalker
took a while before he could build his
own lightsaber so John boyega is going
to start the path to becoming a Jedi in
episode 7 he's probably going to be
using someone else's lightsaber when he
first starts so what's gonna happen is
I'm gonna post my next game of Thrones
bonus video for this week i think i said
i was going to do the horn of winter so
that's probably it's going to be about
be sure to subscribe to get that
hopefully I'll be able to finish that by
later tonight if I don't then I'll just
roll it into tomorrow morning if there
isn't any other like really crazy news
from Monday what I'll probably do in
addition to my Game of Thrones bonus
video that I usually do is I'll do a Q&A
for all the Marvel stuff that happened
this weekend I'll do like a civil war
Q&A for Micah for all the Marvel stuff
and Doctor Strange so much awesome stuff
to go crazy about while you guys wait
for me to finish those videos you can
click here for my breakdown of the civil
war footage like the actual civil war
footage they showed off and you can
click here for a breakdown of all the
doctor strange stuff that they showed up
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight me me me he me anything
you